hey guys welcome back to a brand new
monster on a world video and today we're
gonna be talking about tempered
footprints so basically to get you
caught up to speed after you beat the
campaign you beat xeno you have the
availability to fight tempered monsters
which are basically the same as normal
monsters except they do more damage they
don't have any increased health or
anything they just hit you harder you
could tell what enemy you're fighting is
tempered because they will have a purple
icon surrounding their character in the
investigations last quest screen but it
won't be in-game so it's only in the
quest screen when you go to accept one
when you beat the game you're gonna be
HR 13 and then from HR 13 to 29 you're
gonna be fighting threat level 1
monsters after you beat the quest at HR
29 it unlocks again at HR 30 and then
from 30 to 49 you're gonna be fighting
threat level 2 monsters and then once
that happens you have to complete
another quest to unlock HR 50 and have
the ability to fight tempered elder
dragons then you can continue forever
until you want to stop or capcom
releases more monsters at higher HR
ranks but for the moment you're 100%
done to find tempered enemies you're
gonna need to find their footprints
there's your scalp flies are gonna be
marked blue instead of green when you
find some except the only problem is
that they are pretty rare and not so
common and are kind of hard to find so
that's what the purpose of this video is
gonna be today so to start we're gonna
talk about where to find threat level 1
monster tracks and we're gonna be going
to the wild spire wastes for this one so
in the wild Spahr wastes there's two
paths that I found the first path is to
go to the first camp and slide down that
hill right ahead of you
go past the watered swampy area and in
this arc way there should be two
footprints right underneath and then if
you continue forward there should be two
more passed the stream of water there
isn't many and I looked around that area
I couldn't find any more but those are
some quick four footprints for you right
there
the next set of footprints I found is in
the exact same direction instead go down
the hill like before there should be
footprints right there then go to the
waterfall near where Jareau should spawn
and some of those should appear there as
well continue through the hole in the
wall that leads that rocky area and
there should be some footprints behind
the tower of rocks and then to finish
take a left
pick up the footprints and then grab the
mucus or mud track spot on the wall
straight ahead you may have to go to a
different map and then come back for the
footprints to reset because sometimes
they don't even appear so you could go
to the wild spire wastes get the
footprints go to the ancient forest and
then come back to the wilds bar waste
and they should be there
for threat level two footprints I
started at the elder recess and grabbed
the footprint in the southern West part
of the map where the lava CI lives I'm
pretty sure I butchered that name but
it's the big lava fish in the southwest
part of the map then go to the coral
Highlands and pick up the Kiran tracks
at the place where you fight Kiran as
well some tracks in the area below that
you're currently in afterwards I go up
to where leggy honest leaps and then
grab that claw mark or fur patch
whatever it happens to be and then
that's usually my run eventually you
want to do this enough times to get an
investigation from it now this works for
both threat level one two and most
importantly three as well but for
obviously this case we're gonna be
focusing on one and two so to explain it
better I'll use this chart from a reddit
user named Ray bunny so shout-out to you
so for example if I find tempered
footprints of Oda Garen and he gives me
an investigation from those footprints
the quest could possibly have me hunt
down a Diablos or Rathalos because
they're within the same threat level
same obviously goes for threat level one
and three if I am hunting in if I find
engine at footprints I'll beginning any
monster and and I get an investigation
from it the monster will be any threat
level 1 monster it's not the exact
monster you get the footprints from its
with any monster within that threat
level so the whole point of this is to
basically farm the footprints to get an
investigation out of it and then get to
the next part which we'll talk about in
a second once you get an investigation
that suits your needs whether you need
to get HR 13 or HR 30 quest do the quest
and equip the ghillie mantle and then
hide behind the monster and grab its
footprints without being seen so you can
get more investigations because
obviously the track the tempered monster
you have to track its footprints so if
the monster is no clue you're there it's
just gonna keep walking and making more
footprints like in this clip that I'm
showing with Oda Garen I had the ghillie
mantle on and I just followed behind him
and kept picking up his tracks until I
got more investigations once that
happens you just want to rinse and
repeat those for an endless loop until
you hit the next rank so if you're
fighting let's say a monster that is
very easy for you you can kill them in
like 10 to 15 minutes because member
they don't have any increased health
they just have they just do more damage
so if you're pretty comfortable with
let's say fighting Rathalos and you get
a Rathalos quest you basically want to
dedicate maybe 5 or 10 minutes of the
fight unless it's a very like 15 minute
fight if it's a 50 minute fight you want
to dedicate maybe 5 to 10 minutes just
following behind them in your ghillie
mantle picking up as footprints and
taken and
and then keep redoing that every single
time you do the investigation because
you obviously get five to eight attempts
on these so you can keep doing this
consistently and getting tons of
investigations and you can never lose
any so just to recap if your HR 13 to 29
to find fight the threat level one
monster and get those footprints by
using the wild spire waste waste past I
showed then once you hit HR 30 find the
footprints in the elder recess and the
coral highlands and continue farming
monsters until you HR 52 then fight
tempered Elder Dragons I myself have yet
to reach HR 50 I believe I'm HR 35 well
but once I do I will also be doing a
guide on how to get tempered elder
dragon footprints cuz as I've heard
they're a little bit more difficult to
come by so definitely stay tuned for
that I mean that guys that's going to be
the end of the video hope you guys did
enjoy I hope this was very informative I
saw a few people a little bit confused
about tempered stuff about tempered
footprints so I thought I'd explain that
a little bit more since I have a little
bit more knowledge on it now like the
video if you guys did enjoy I really do
appreciate you sticking around subscribe
if you're new I cover a lot of monster 2
content like guides tutorials other
stuff like that the solo guides have
been coming out with I have another one
coming soon of course I just wanted to
fit this in because we've been doing a
lot of solo guides and I'd rather put
this in the video has a little bit of a
break my two most recent Monster Hunter
world videos are gonna be on screen if
you guys did miss those definitely check
that out but that guys hope you have a
great esterday and peace out